okay um we're going to uh bring this
committee meeting to order um thank you
all for being here 30 minutes or what is
it 30 minutes before your respective
caucuses uh quick uh quick pledge and
then we'll dispense with the bill um I
will lead
it I pledge allegiance to the flag of
Amica okay um actually I need to grab
me
okay I'm opening up the executive
session hearing on Executive session on
retain bill sb221 is there a
motion somebody like to make a motion of
itl please I so move moved by
representative D Simone is there a
second I'll second is there a second is
there any
discussion excellent hearing no
discussion uh the clerk do I will call
the role do we have our clerk ready to
on Chan's not our clerk so I will be the
clerk real quickly excuse me
me so you can tell I left late today you
can all just say our names and yeah but
we have to have it for the record though
I think right
so um all right well it's fine we'll do
the voting and then I think I know how
it's going to go um representing money
would you like to vote first I I
representative moror walner
representative Phillips I representative
ball hi representative Nelson yes
representative Paige yes representative
MC Williams yes and the chair votes yes
and with that we have a unanimous 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 uh to0 um vote and with that I
will close executive session uh before
releas the committee I am going to
schedule all these retained bills the
way I'm going to schedule them is I'm
going to go through um with the ranking
member I'm going to find find the ones
that I think we could find consensus on
we'll schedule those first the ones
where I think we think there might be
division on I will schedule those in the
back end so we can get our good work
done first and leave the not fun stuff
to the end with that I'm going to close
the executive session thank you all for
being here oh one quick thing I do think
represent MC Williams and I was talking
on the way in I do think you will get to
claim mileage today because you went to
a committee meeting which is outside of
a constitutional provision I do not know
that to be certain so don't don't hold
me to it but I do think you will be able
to thank you so much bye which means you
office